remember this is not the first time
America has had to be able to race as
president this is not the worst thing
we've ever seen to say that would be to
this disregard the Trail of Tears that
natives face and in slavery but when you
know history you know that's not the
only side of our American history either
there's another place about this
tomorrow DNA and that that is people
have always stood up number one if you
won't change America you got to change
it from state houses up the Koch
brothers came down to the state houses
and that's where they got their power
the worst laws about voting and living
wage and education happen in state
legislatures secondly you have to build
a new language to poor people together
because left and right automatically
sets people apart
so the way we did it we had moral Monday
as a rally in point every Monday issue
focused for 10 years North Carolina had
been trying to raise the minimum wage
had not been successful for when we came
together black and white and Latino Jew
and Christian and Muslim and Hindu
people of faith people not a faith gay
and straight Republicans and Democrats
around this moral agenda and we stopped
talking left and right and liberal
versus conservative button what morally
defensible we want you have to be able
to hold race and class together
sometimes progressives say let's find a
way to cut across race you have to cut
into it you can't say race or classes
race and class lastly you have to have a
legal strategy where we're willing to
dust off the Constitution and fight
against unconstitutional laws and you
have to build a movement not a moment
not at one rally not one tweet not one
letter the moral Monday movement set the
framework of showing that in the south
you can organize black and white and
brown people you can bring them together
when you reframe the issues around the
Constitution around morality and around
what is economically just and you can
win so I believe that all of these
movements form our on Monday to fight 15
as I've said black lives matter on and
on and on by signs of hope that people
are going to stand up and not stand down
the people are saying standing down is
not
if we if we were able to beat back slave
if we were able to beat that Jim Crow
then women were able to reap win the
right to vote there maybe this is just
our time and from that standpoint I'm
glad to be alive and glad to be allowed
with so many others who say we will
never give up on the heart of this
democracy we are going to be the moral
defibrillators of our time and shock the
heart of this nation and build a
movement of resistance and hope and
justice
you